you know i saw a comment the other day
talking none of my videos but
complaining about
sanderson's use of humor and it reminded
me of a scene that
literally made me laugh out loud like
it's like you know how people say like
oh that book was so hilarious like if i
read a funny book i'm not like
laughing i'm just like this is my
reaction i just read something funny
that's really funny in a book
that's it you know that's my that's my
reaction there is a
scene in oathbringer where i actually
stopped laughed
and read the scene to my wife who has no
idea who these characters are but it's
still funny and at work the scene really
shows a sense of humanity chapter 55
in oathbringer titled alone together the
members of bridge 4
are talking about renarin and how he is
basically learning how to read which is
considered a feminine trait theology
culture considers it a feminine trait
the men in bridge four are getting a
little
weirded out right a little bit of toxic
masculinity there but they end
up discussing dre's sexuality
first off i just want to say this about
fantasy books science fiction
you can literally do anything you can do
anything in story so why why create a
world that is
equally if not more homophobic than our
own of course that that comes down to
choices of the writer i'm not saying a
writer has to do these things i'm just
saying
why not i'll just read the passage so
caledon asked what's the problem sigsel
can read his own language
storms i can read glyphs it's not the
same scar said
it's feminine dre said dre caledon said
you are literally courting a man so
dre said yeah what are you saying cal
scar snapped nothing i just thought dre
might
empathize that's hardly fair dre said
yeah lopin added dre likes other guys
that's like he wants to be even less
around women than the rest of us
it's the opposite of feminine he is you
could say
extra man so i don't know
how funny that is combination of like
how sexist
the men are being while also not having
this
internalized homophobia really
appreciate brandon sanderson for
including
pieces of humor like that it's just
funny i don't know
that's definitely the funniest moment
i've read
in the books but what do you all think
about this scene what specific moment in
the stormlight archive made you laugh
the most because
honestly sanderson doesn't get enough
appreciation for
his humor that's all i gotta say have a
good one bye